it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share with you some items that
might make your day a little bit easier
and holiday shopping a little bit easier
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping go ahead and scan the QR code
on your screen right now or you can
visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass is
with us good morning good morning and
you know what I don't know if you guys
are familiar with this especially you
Gail but apparently Oprah Winfrey has
very good taste because this is one of
her favorite things I love it this is
the revolution cooking toaster with
it is a touch screen you see on the
front so when you touch the screen you
can select Frozen items toast Bagels but
you can also make grilled cheese
sandwiches and for me from the southwest
I can make my quesadillas in this
exactly great and it has so many
different settings yeah depending on how
you want multiple settings you just open
it up boom lock it in and yeah wow
before you get to the price I do want to
test this toaster so I brought a little
bit of bread from home oh the man with
the toast with the most this is the
second okay
really know whether it toast properly I
gotta go with the home step on over here
here we go we're going to touch the
screen I'm just going to press bread
start and boom it goes down it's like
Star Trek look at that and what's great
is in your kitchen you can just remove
all the other items and leaves this I
know how much
that's what I was thinking too any candy
yeah
Tony CBS would have bought you some
bread
be a perfect time what's the price this
is as CBS deals exclusive you want to
get this in the next 24 hours we have it
for 369. that's 60 off and this could be
the one beautiful thing that you could
put on your countertop I mean look how
cool it is also a great Christmas gift
yeah yes even if somebody has a toaster
you can see the timer yeah it's toasting
you can see the timer of a toast and
it'll count it down to like 10 so you're
not sticking your finger in all right so
we're going to wait to hear for the
sound yes we'll wait for that wait for
the Bell here uh this is for your furry
friends this is to help uh hydrate your
your help your drop your dog's
dehydrated this is the Springer and it's
really great let me demonstrate for you
because all you do is press and it fills
with water right not press excuse me you
squeeze and fill with water yeah this is
very it's like that because usually you
got a water bottle then you got to look
around for a cup find a place yeah for
your dog what I love about it is how
lightweight it is because Gail knows I
like to hike and when you take your dog
with you a lot of these are really
really heavy but if you feel this one
it's lightweight when you strap it on
it's not going to weigh down your
backpack if you're going on a longer
hike this also we have on a great price
we have this for 30 off it's 17 so what
a great gift for your dog in the
stockings I was thinking about you Gail
because when we first met you the very
first time you were talking about your
beloved Walt Walter who I know is no
longer with us you okay I'm okay okay
because I know that's I've had that loss
I know you know what so I was wondering
how you're going to do showing this it's
all good you know what I'm good with
Walter being gone because I had him for
nine years he was a rescue he was a pit
mix who loved watching CBS mornings I
posted a picture I've been watching you
and loved you okay and then you have
from the dog water can what's this yes
we're having a moment for it this is a
moment for everybody who has to sit at
home and work at a desk all day or maybe
in the office you put this thing on this
is the calming Heap or wreck it's cold
oh yeah back right yeah cold
um I could turn it on to three different
levels of heat it has three different
levels of vibrating go ahead Gail you
can touch my back you can feel that oh
it's vibrating and like like right there
that's why you were moving and it has
lumbar support that's very that's very
nice it helps you stand up straight
what's the price the price on this is 47
we have it for 40 off wow that's a great
thing and by the way guys let's break
bread yeah and I heard a little BBB
popped out yeah all right toast man all
right Gail bass thank you so much and of
course we partner with all of these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything that you saw into other
products scan the QR code on your screen
right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start happy now it's a
holiday season